[Musique]
un qui va y aller en tout cas c'est
Pascal Bruner parce qu'il a choisi je
crois neuf chansons de votre répertoire
il vous a framé de lait Pascal Bruner
[Musique]
ok voici pour 100 franc du thin de la
garigue un peu de safran et un kilo de
figue voulez-vous pas vrai un beau C de
pêche ou bien d'abricot voici
l'estragons et la belle échalote le joli
poisson de la Marie Charlotte
voulez-vous pas vrai un bouquet de
Lavand ou bien quelques
illet et par-dessus tout
ça on vous offre en
étain tu as vu je l'ai bien mis la main
la
salle qui se
promène et qui n'en
finit
pas
les cerises sembl les oiseaux sont
contents revoilà le
printemps je d mal dans mon lit ma
cousine est trop jolie
ch est normal maman ce merveilleux tourm
qui me fait rougir tout le
temps si je me mariais est-ce que tu me
jamais
[Musique]
ok mademoiselle
lises
mademoiselle mais ce soir je suis décidé
on va danser on
danserand viol et les ro
l'accordéonud avoir de jambes de bois
pour ne pas danser la
Poka la fille amaturin je peux te dire
elle danse bien mais sielle ferme les
yeux je peux te dire elle danse bien
[Musique]
ou je reviens te
chercher je savais que tu
m'attendais je savais que l'on ne
pourrait se passer l'un de l'autre
longtemps je reviens te
chercher mais je vois ça as pas trop
changé oui et je vois que de ton
côté tu as bien traverser le temps on va
monter le
temps je reviens te chercher
ouis je suis tremblant comme un jeune
marié mais plus riche qu'au jour
passé de
tendresse et de larmes et de
temps je reviens te
chercher
j'ai l'erbê sur ce
palis
aide-moi et bien
m'embrasser un taxi est en bas
[Musique]
qui je reviens te chercher et
oui on a besoin de toi
maintenant
quand il est mort le
poète j'ai l'impression que je suis
mort uneologie ou
quoi tous ses
amis tous ses
amis ple
pleur
quand il es mort le poète c'est à
toi quand il est mort le
[Musique]
poète le monde
entier bien c'est un snavour ça entier
c'est snavour le
mond pleureer on va encore en faire une
a Gilbert
ok ce matin je sors de chez moi il
m'attendait il était là il saait sur le
trottoir mon Dieu qu'il est c'est drôle
av voir le petit oiseau de toutes les
couleurs le petit oiseau de toutes les
couleurs o tu m'entraîn o tu m'emmèes ma
passit attends-moi comme c'est tuas
rendez-vous là où tu vas je vais avec
toi
[Musique]
ok non mais c'est rare c'est bien quand
même
hein
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]